Narrator: IN 1903,
GEOLOGIST DANIEL BARRINGER
PAYS $250,000
FOR A 640-ACRE METEOR CRATER
IN THE DESERT WEST OF
WINSLOW, ARIZONA.
THIS CRATER IS OF GREAT INTEREST
TO DANIEL BARRINGER
BECAUSE HE THINKS IT MIGHT BE A
SOURCE OF A LARGE IRON DEPOSIT.
THIS COULD BE THE JACKPOT
FOR DANIEL BARRINGER.
AS FAR AS HE'S CONCERNED,
HE MIGHT MAKE MILLIONS
OR EVEN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FROM THIS MATERIAL.
Narrator: BARRINGER ESTIMATES
THAT THE METEORITE
THAT MADE THE CRATER
HAD A MASS OF 100 MILLION TONS.
HE HOPES LARGE QUANTITIES OF IT
ARE STILL BURIED
UNDER ITS FLOOR.
BARRINGER SPENDS
A NUMBER OF YEARS
EXCAVATING AROUND THE CRATER,
DRILLING DOWN TO GREAT DEPTHS.
AND YET FINDS
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
Narrator: TODAY, GEOLOGISTS
CALCULATE THE METEORITE
WAS IN FACT 300 TIMES SMALLER
THAN BARRINGER BELIEVED.
AND NONE OF IT
WOULD HAVE SURVIVED
ITS CATACLYSMIC COLLISION
WITH EARTH.
THE OBJECT THAT MADE
METEOR CRATER
HITS THE GROUND AT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MILES AN HOUR.
AND AS IT HITS THE GROUND,
THERE'S SO MUCH PRESSURE
ON THAT INCOMING ASTEROID
THAT THAT PRESSURE WAVE SHOOTS
THROUGH THE ASTEROID.
THE TEMPERATURE RISES,
AND THE WHOLE THING VAPORIZES.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
A SHOCK WAVE PROPELS ITSELF
INTO THE GROUND
AND EXCAVATES THE CRATER.